[Aplausos]
[Música]
érase una vez junto a un aeropuerto
militar de estar talado y repleto de
viejos helicópteros y cazas soviéticos
una pequeña ciudad llamada san antonio
de los baños una ciudad de origen
colonial conocida como la capital del
humor 10 este es el lugar donde se
celebra el festival bienal internacional
del humorismo gráfico sin embargo desde
julio del 2021 bien podría empezar a ser
más conocida como el epicentro cubano
del mal humor y del descontento social
emotivos motivos no faltan cuba sufre la
peor escasez de alimentos desde los años
90 cuba reconoce grave escasez de
medicamentos aquí en san antonio de los
baños es donde comenzó todo es el sitio
donde explotó el hartazgo popular y en
primer lugar en el que la gente perdió
el miedo y aparecieron las primeras
protestas masivas contra el régimen
cubano ni más ni menos que desde 1994
[Música]
unas protestas que tal y como veis
tuvieron su origen fuera de la habana y
que rápidamente se extendieron a lo
largo y ancho de todo el país y sobre
todo por las provincias de mayabeque y
matanzas donde por ejemplo se encuentra
el hub turístico de varadero también
fueron muy numerosas las concentraciones
de protesta en la propia capital en la
mismísima habana en esta ocasión las
protestas han sido un tanto extrañas no
sólo porque ver protestas en una
dictadura comunista como la cubana sea
algo poco frecuente sino también porque
es la primera vez que una ola de
protestas a gran escala al menos en
términos cubanos se inicia fuera de la
capital
[Música]
a diferencia de lo que ocurre en otros
países latinoamericanos el régimen
comunista que gobierna cuba desde hace
ya más de 60 largos años ha logrado
instaurar una institucionalidad fuerte
que alcanza todos los rincones del país
algo que le otorga a la dictadura una
posición de amplio dominio y control
sobre el conjunto de la población de
hecho el régimen cubano es uno de los
pocos regímenes comunistas que pese a
todas las dificultades consiguió
sobrevivir a la caída del muro de berlín
y el colapso de la unión soviética es
más el régimen sobrevivió incluso a la
gran crisis económica que sufrió el país
entre 1990 y 1994 una crisis que causó
un recrudecimiento del racionamiento y
una escasez material muy acusada que se
extiende hasta el día de hoy un periodo
en el que cuba perdió en tan sólo tres
años el 36 por ciento de su pib y un
golpe del que el país tardaría en
recuperarse más de 17 años
y es que veréis la unión soviética era
para cuba mucho más que un aliado
político fue durante décadas el
auténtico motor económico de la isla
[Música]
por ejemplo la urss le vendía a cuba
petróleo a precios preferenciales
petróleo que luego en parte los cubanos
se exportaban para conseguir dólares
recibían de moscú también créditos
blandos
esto es créditos a muy largo plazo con
bajísimos tipos de interés y facilidades
para devolverlos bien obtenían
compensaciones por la presencia de
tropas del ejército rojo y exportaban el
grueso de su producción al mercado
soviético para que os hagáis una idea
aproximadamente el 70 por ciento de todo
el comercio de cuba se dirigía hacia la
unión de repúblicas socialistas
soviéticas okupa fue más dependiente de
la urss de lo que había sido de españa y
de eeuu sin tomar su historia juan
triana economista cubano por eso cuando
la urss vino abajo la economía cubana
colapsó fueron años muy duros de crisis
durante los cuales incluso el consumo de
calorías de los cubanos se redujo casi
un 30 por ciento fue una etapa conocida
como el período especial años de
penurias extremas que terminaron
alimentando un estallido social el
maleconazo
[Música]
a principios de agosto de 1994 las
autoridades cubanas detuvieron a cuatro
embarcaciones que se dirigían hacia eeuu
escapando de la crisis que azotaba la
isla fue la gota que colmó el vaso
cientos y cientos de personas se
concentraron en el malecón de la habana
enfrentándose con palos y piedras contra
la policía al tiempo que lanzaban
consignas contra el entonces presidente
dictador fidel castro'
pero sin embargo y pese a todo ahí
continúa el régimen comunista asentado
en el poder contra viento y marea
bueno una expresión que en cuba
podríamos adaptar y decir contra la
crisis y miseria pero como resiste el
régimen como es posible que a pesar de
todo el régimen siga cerrado al mundo a
la en libertad de la modernidad acá el
canto pues tal y como decíamos es algo
que han conseguido gracias a la
institucionalidad que han extendido por
todo el país
si una institucionalidad totalitaria
pero institucionalidad al fin y al cabo
la construcción político institucional
del régimen cubano y está en buena
medida ha heredada de la experiencia
soviética mantiene estructuras de poder
muy depuradas a nivel de gobierno y
ejército es decir no hay traidores ni
luchas internas relevantes y además el
gobierno cuenta con uno de los mejores
servicios de seguridad e inteligencia de
toda latinoamérica es precisamente por
eso por lo que a pesar de todas las
crisis que ha sufrido la isla el sueño
de conquistar la libertad y la
democracia parece aún muy lejano y muy
difícil de alcanzar para los propios
cubanos ahora bien de gozas de punto
apuesto a que lo que la mayoría os estés
preguntando es cómo demonios hemos
llegado a ver las imágenes que hemos
visto de protestas multitudinarias en
cuba' qué elementos han descorchado la
botella y causando semejante explosión
social cuál es el origen de todas estas
protestas y tal vez la pregunta más
importante de todas se van a repetir se
repetirán y lograrán de una vez por
todas tumbar al régimen más pronto que
tarde' bien todos sabéis lo que ocurrió
así que en este vídeo os vamos a contar
exactamente qué fue lo que prendió la
mecha y como vemos el escenario que se
ha dibujado en cuba' atentos
[Música]
pero un momento antes de continuar le
habéis echado ya un vistazo a si lo
hubiera sabido
[Música]
es un nuevo canal de información y
análisis financiero impulsado por muto
activos con el que participamos como
protegió la bolsa del ahorro de los
argentinos que ocurre con la economía
china como está siendo la recuperación
post covite en los eeuu y efectos pueden
tener las políticas de los bancos
centrales cuáles son las nuevas mega
tendencias que dominan las bolsas éstas
son amigos algunas de las preguntas a
las que este nuevo canal pretende
responder echarle un vistazo porque
merece la pena os dejamos el link por
aquí también abajo en la descripción ya
nos contarás qué te parece y ahora si
arranquemos una irrefrenable ola de
libertad la cuba del 2021 no es la cuba
del año 2000 ni siquiera la del 2015 el
país ha vivido importantes cambios
sociales que hasta hace pocos años
hubieran sido simple y llanamente
impensables cambios que si bien no se
han reflejado en el gobierno ni tampoco
en una mejora de la economía o las
libertades políticas si han cambiado
cuba en algunas cosas por ejemplo y a
pesar de toda la propaganda del régimen
la mayor parte de las nuevas
generaciones
ya no ven a eeuu como una gente hostil
sino como una especie de objetivo al que
poder llegar a ser algún día en todos
los cambios que se han producido hay
algo que ha marcado un antes y un
después a llegada del internet móvil de
hecho este ha sido uno de los factores
que más ha movilizado a la gente en las
protestas de julio del 2021 hablamos de
un servicio que en la isla caribeña no
existía hasta hace relativamente poco
tiempo 2018 comenzará el 6 de diciembre
y servicios de internet de los móviles a
través de la compañía estatal de
telecomunicaciones etecsa el único
proveedor de internet del país los
cubanos ya pueden acceder a internet en
cualquier lugar desde la palma de sus
manos es algo que ha abierto las puertas
a una fuerza muy difícil de contener
[Música]
aunque el internet en cuba está
censurado gracias a redes vpn los
cubanos ha logrado abrirse una ventana
al mundo exterior y entre otras cosas
ahora pueden hablar directamente y sin
filtros con sus familiares y amigos que
están en españa' o miami
evidentemente este es el mejor antídoto
contra la propaganda política claro que
no solo se trata de hablar internet
también les ha permitido acceder a
información masiva información virgen
sin que haya sido censurada previamente
por las autoridades comunistas ahora
pueden conocer el mundo exterior
descubre el puntos de vista políticos
diferentes organizarse e incluso
participar en debates políticos toda una
revolución nunca mejor dicho en la isla
de cuba
[Música]
ahora los cubanos comprueban sin fisuras
las consecuencias de estar encerrados en
una isla cuyo gobierno parece detenido
en el tiempo mientras que sus
compatriotas emigrantes prosperan en el
resto del mundo y luego para colmo está
la decepción la enorme frustración con
el nuevo gobierno cubano
[Música]
y es que veréis cuando raúl castro
comenzó a ceder los mandos al nuevo
líder político de la isla el presidente
miguel díaz canel se generó una enorme
expectación sería éste el líder por fin
que promoviera la apertura y el cambio
de cuba empresa y prioridad que él se
mostró partidario de realizar
importantes reformas abril cuba al mundo
permitir la iniciativa privada o la
inversión extranjera directa es decir el
cambio de rumbo que tantas dictaduras
comunistas han protagonizado con el paso
de los años y sí es verdad que se
produjeron algunos cambios empezando por
el acceso a internet sin embargo todo ha
sido muy lento demasiado lento
desesperadamente lento hasta el punto de
que apenas han mejorado la situación
económica y desde luego no han cumplido
expectativas al final amigos todo esto
es relativamente fácil de explicar lo
que quieren los cubanos del 2021 sobre
todos los jóvenes es algo muy sencillo
quieren tener los móviles de último
modelo que sus primos que viven en
madrid ya tienen dos coches y conducen
sus tíos
a mi poder hablar de lo que les dé la
gana sin miedo a represalias o
simplemente poder viajar quieren tener
un futuro y una vida normal algo que el
actual gobierno no parece dispuesto ni
tampoco preparado para darles y eso es
precisamente lo que ha hecho que se haya
ido forjando una cierta conciencia
general acerca de que la vida que hoy
tienen simplemente no funciona no está
bien y todo en nombre de una revolución
que ellos jamás apoyaron para colmo la
generación que más ha protestado es una
generación quien nació durante el
conocido como periodo especial el
periodo de fuerte crisis económica que
como ya hemos visto se produjo tras el
colapso de la unión soviética en
definitiva esta es una generación que
nunca ha experimentado otra cosa que
crisis represión racionamiento y pobreza
como no van a estar hartos además es que
no tienen nada que perder queridos
amigos
las protestas significaron una cosa que
los cubanos están perdiendo el miedo
ahora bien que fue exactamente lo que
prendió la mecha a alguna idea concreta
atentos
[Música]
éramos pocos y parió katana
para entender los motivos que llevaron a
que la olla social finalmente explotara
en julio del 2021 tenemos que meter en
la ecuación al coronavirus del momento
de preparar este vídeo cuba lleva ya
varios meses sufriendo una fuerte oleada
de contagios una oleada que ha sido
literalmente importada del exterior con
el beneplácito del propio gobierno
cubano y es que veréis el turismo supone
una importantísima fuente de ingresos
para el régimen y por tanto es vital
para su propia existencia
[Música]
atentos por ejemplo a este nombre a ese
grupo de administración empresarial es
una organización un consorcio propiedad
de las fuerzas armadas cubanas una
especie de holding empresarial que
controla todo tipo de activos tiendas de
distribución minorista puertos y sobre
todo hoteles siempre pensado en la
economía y en el gobierno de cuba como
en una cebolla o con una de esas muñecas
rusas que contienen otras más pequeñas
dentro yo nunca he visto la última
matrioska he visto tres o cuatro y creo
que lo mismo pasa con una institución
como a esa pedro freire abogado del
consejo de negocios estados unidos-cuba
de la cámara de comercio de eeuu
en esta línea gaesa controla el grupo de
turismo gaviota un conglomerado que a su
vez es propietario de los hoteles más
importantes de la isla hablamos de más
de 83 instalaciones hoteleras que suman
unas 29 mil habitaciones y facturan en
condiciones normales más de 700 millones
de dólares pues bien si en el 2019 la
llegada de turistas a cuba ya cayó
considerablemente un 6 por ciento en
2020 los resultados fueron catastróficos
a causa de la pandemia
el número de turistas internacionales
que llegaron a la isla se redujo a
prácticamente cero y con ello el
gobierno cubano dejó de ingresar cerca
de tres mil millones de dólares y aunque
en 2021 la cosa ha mejorado un poco
respecto al año anterior el sector
turístico cubano sigue muy lejos de las
cifras de años anteriores así que claro
ante semejante situación cualquier
ingreso contaba
[Música]
[Aplausos]
precisamente por eso el gobierno de díaz
canel decidió mirar hacia otro lado
respecto a la pandemia y fomentar la
llegada de turistas internacionales sin
ninguna restricción turistas que
llegaron sobre todo procedentes del país
que más crecimiento del turismo hacia
cuba ha experimentado durante los
últimos años la madre rusia el problema
los rusos estaban sufriendo una violenta
ola del coronavirus causada por la
variante delta y la inmensa mayoría
todavía estaban sin vacunar y eso eso es
lo que explican noticias como este más
de 150 turistas rusos están aislados en
cuba tras dar positivo al kobe 19 y ojo
porque no fue un caso aislado la llegada
de turistas fundamentalmente rusos
empezó a causar brotes en hoteles que
luego a través de los trabajadores
acabaron expandiéndose por todo el país
aunque afectaron particularmente a la
provincia de matanzas que es donde se
encuentra varadero el epicentro cubano
del turismo de sol y playa la
propagación de los contagios colapsó el
maltrecho sistema sanitario cubano y
provocó una escasez aún más severa de lo
que ya es habitual en medicamentos y
productos básicos
ahora bien seguro que os estáis
preguntando
a ver por qué demonios abrieron las
puertas desde emergente forma el turismo
procedente de países en pleno repunte de
la pandemia por las nuevas variantes
pues amigos simple y llanamente porque
el régimen necesitaba dinero dinero
urgente
e
[Música]
la crisis turística del 2020 en cuba- es
la que en buena forma explica por que
ahora los cubanos tienen que hacer
largas colas para intentar comprar algo
de comida en el supermercado yo es que
veréis la cuestión es que la comida en
cuba es fundamentalmente importada
porque el país sólo produce en torno al
20 por ciento de la demanda local
hablamos de unos 1.800 millones de
dólares en importaciones de alimentos
cada año compras que se realizan en el
mercado internacional y que se tienen
que pagar en dólares o euros
[Música]
y cuál es la principal fuente de dólares
y de euros para cuba exacto el turismo y
cómo en 2020 apenas hubo turismo eso
significa que conseguir los dólares con
los que el régimen importa los alimentos
se vuelve algo muy complicado
particularmente cuando eres un país como
cuba del que nadie se fía y a quien
nadie le quiere prestar y ahí ahí es
donde surge la escasez severa que ha
castigado y sigue castigando a los
cubanos es la pescadilla que se muerde
la cola
una economía fuertemente restringida y
muy improductiva un sistema de empresas
estatales completamente disfuncional y
no sujeto a criterios de mercado un
control extremo de todo lo que entra en
la isla en fin
en definitiva el cóctel perfecto para el
desastre quizás con todo el mayor error
de cálculo protagonizado por el gobierno
de díaz canel es que jamás pensaron que
la situación se iba a descontrolar hasta
el punto de desatarse las mayores
protestas de la historia de cuba
protestas incluso mayores que las del
maleconazo del 94 para que os hagáis una
idea en un solo día se llegaron a
registrar 40 manifestaciones lo que
evidentemente no es algo normal en un
país gobernado con puño de hierro como
éste de hecho en los días de más
afluencia de las protestas las cuales
llegaron al king art calles y plazas en
la habana al dictador cubano díaz canel
se le veía bastante nervioso en sus
comunicados e incluso instó al
enfrentamiento civil entre partidarios y
detractores del gobierno tienen que
pasar por encima de nuestros cadáveres
si quieren enfrentar a la revolución y
estamos dispuestos a todos y estaremos
en las calles combatiendo y por eso
también aquí estamos convocando
a todos revolucionarios del país a todos
los comunistas a que salgan a las calles
en cualquiera de los lugares donde se
vayan a producir estas provocaciones a
la revolución defendemos ante todos los
revolucionarios y en la primera fila los
comunistas
amigos los llamamientos de díaz canel
pusieron en evidencia una cosa quizás el
régimen cubano todavía no esté a punto
de caer pero no es tan sólido como se
pensaba
transporta el internet e incluso la
electricidad para dificultar las
reuniones y desplegar a las fuerzas de
seguridad las protestas fueron
desapareciendo las fuerzas policiales y
militares han tomado la habana y las
principales ciudades del país los boinas
negras el cuerpo de élite de represión
cubana y hombres civiles armados con
tubos de pvc y palos de madera se pasean
en grupo por las ciudades para intimidar
a la población
por cierto los boinas negras
oficialmente denominados como la brigada
especial nacional son un cuerpo político
policial cuya función básica es actuar
como escuadrón de choque de la dictadura
cubana ante cualquier muestra de
disidencia se crearon hace algo más de
40 años y visten de negro para intimidar
son algo así como la guardia pretoriana
del régimen comunista
nos enfrentamos para defender la
revolución y para defender nuestras
conquistas han alberto soriano vida al
mayor de la brigada especial nacional
pero no nos desviemos vale puede que aún
no haya llegado el final de la satrapía
en cuba pero cuánto tiempo más aguantar
a la dictadura cubana
por lo pronto hoy ha tenido que ceder en
algo que parecía infranqueable hasta
hace sólo un mes las restricciones a las
importaciones privadas uva deja de
limitar la importación privada de
alimentos y medicinas lo que por cierto
resulta curioso muchas veces se habla
del embargo norteamericano que no
bloqueo que castiga a la isla pero nunca
del embargo establecido por el propio
gobierno cubano esto es los límites a
comerciar con el exterior en cualquier
caso si algo queda claro es que la
explosión social sin precedentes que se
han vivido en julio del 221
ha sido todo un grito desesperado que
aunque no haya logrado tumbar a la
dictadura si ha servido para que las
ansias de democracia en cuba se escuchen
en todo el mundo y es justo aquí cuando
llegamos a la futura agenda política
[Música]
amigos seamos claros si el partido
comunista de cuba quiere seguir
gobernando en la isla va a tener más
remedio que realizar reformas económicas
reales reformas orientadas al mercado
como hizo la china deben shaoping en
cambio si continúan negándose a cambiar
de modelo puede que muy pronto la marea
se los lleve por delante o puede incluso
que la comunidad internacional diga
basta lo que viene siendo una situación
insostenible desde hace décadas una
represiva y anticuada dictadura
comunista a unos pocos kilómetros de
miami pero que es hasta aquí turno para
ti
estarán díaz-canel sus secuaces
dispuestos a modernizar cuba con tal de
conservar sus sillones saldrá de estas
protestas una cuba con más libertades
sociales y económicas o por el contrario
el gobierno para por el camino de
reprimir más y más que exposición deberá
adoptar la comunidad internacional
podéis dejarnos vuestra opinión aquí
abajo en los comentarios y por cierto si
te gusta este vídeo no olvides darle a
me gusta y suscribirte al canal dándole
a la campanita para no perderte ninguna
actualización una vez más gracias por
estar allí un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]